hey guys I'm Ryan I'm Jerry we're gonna
react to the trailer of sabotage was
sabotage starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
and the Beastie Boy I don't know [ __ ]
about this movie I really know I didn't
know that this was a movie until you
pulled it up just now
okay cool well I'm excited to watch the
show because I'm an Arnold fan I like
Arnold a lot I like doing better or no
impressions mmm
me too get to the job of a to know you
to you a lot do you do more all new
impressions beautiful Expendables 3
Terrence Howard Zinn's the chef this is
the Last Stand all over again I think
the last is austrian-american ever
Arnold keeps footlong tonight between
Mike oh he can act - oh he's dead
this really looks pretty [ __ ] cool
I'm getting chills right now I really
yeah though it's bringing bad meets the
last thing yeah breaking that's Sam
Worthington is it really yeah
terminators a team
this actually looks like a really
well-made movie shows Arnold has some
drama
do you like diet is Ivor doesn't do this
looks like great oil like a good movie
with Arnold Schwarzenegger who needed
one of these love it when movies is
heroes there we go yeah now he's gonna
take revenge in the third act this movie
looks like six movies crammed it - what
and even mentioned Sam earth
you sure it's him yeah sabotage nice
dude that looks surprisingly good looks
pretty cool yeah it looks like a like
good drama and like Harlem looks like
he's trying to reinvent his image a
little bit yeah well I mean he's you
know he's getting back in the game he's
going darker that's the way to do it
Arnold
I mean I it kind of has that sense of
like the trailers most of the movie yeah
especially when that wife and daughter
do every [ __ ] action movie does that
[ __ ] know it's like a girlfriend or wife
and daughter a girlfriend wife daughter
everyone want to have taken things yeah
dude it's like it's getting so [ __ ]
repetitive it was just in the last alone
movie yeah yeah yeah hellhole headboards
of the head yeah so yeah my daughter a
guy oh she's good
dude did do Mickey the sheriff well it
looks like a cross between like the last
name Breaking Bad The Last Stand SWAT
some other like gritty drug bust movie
yeah cuz someone write our training day
and apparently that writer doesn't not
do anything else besides like I got
three hops and drugs but they're like
edgy cops like they could be from the
streets like yeah Oren just got a drawer
oh yeah yeah yeah it looks like almost
got some good movies True Lies is pretty
cool the predator Terminator 2 so almost
not all bad you go all the way jingle
all the way jingle all the way that
cookie down what was the toy called
tuple man - oh man I am tubule mad so my
son like me instead of the hot man you
know I I love that movie
we watched that movie so much growing up
I loved that of my life she can go all
the way - that's what the fans want
Arnold